well if you haven't seen the video on
our video channel you need to go to our
YouTube channel or go and get the app to
the Dave Ramsey show you can download
the free app for your iPhone or iPad
it's free you can watch on our website
at Dave Ramsey comm slash show but if
you haven't seen the video it's one of
the most inspiring things I have seen in
years the video is of Brian Gainey it's
our milestones feature that we have on
our video channel and he has an
incredible incredible story so I'm just
so impressed with him I wanted to bring
him on the air and talk to him for a
minute
so we called him up hey Brian how are
you I'm doing well Dave I am better than
I deserve and thank you for having me on
well we're honored to have you sir your
story is amazing I didn't throw the
punchline I'm going to let you throw it
tell people about what you did sure sure
absolutely well I have been able to
through a lot of persistence and
determination and follow-through I've
been able to lose almost 400 pounds in
the last four years 400 pounds and four
years
that's amazing those watching the video
channel right now are seeing a picture
of the skinny you holding your other
pants from the before you Wow
so what happened that caused you to
become so inspired that you changed your
life
well like you always say Dave you know
we don't ever change anything until we
get absolutely sick and tired and we
just we say no more what had happened
I've been heavy on my life and wound up
at almost 600 pounds and I was
hospitalized I got sick and I was in the
hospital for a week and it was just it
was a really miserable time hospitals
are never fun places and I just got
tired of the limitations I just got sick
and tired I got tired of being told that
I was too big to fit in the machine they
couldn't figure out what was wrong with
me I just I had enough I couldn't take
it anymore
and so I just kept saying over and over
again you know no more limitations no
more not being will fit in the Machine
the hospital
not being able to walk around no more
just no more I remember pounding on the
table just screaming no more and I'm
sure they were probably about to put me
in the psych ward but I just I couldn't
take it anymore and I just decided this
is unacceptable there there will be no
more of this I have had enough I'm 37
years old I don't want to die I want to
enjoy the rest of my life and I just I
couldn't take it anymore I had had
enough and I knew that there had to be a
way now did you have the gastro
restriction surgery I did not it it I
that was pitched to me over and over
again by every doctor every nurse my
health insurance would have paid for it
I would have been free for me but you
know it really what really reminded me
of and I think this is probably the
first time that the debt payoff story
kind of lined up with the weight loss is
there was just something about it that
struck me is just almost like
nutritional bankruptcy like I was just
going to push a button and have the
surgery and all my problems are going to
be washed away and I did a little
research and I certainly don't judge
anyone or their decisions of their
choices but this for me aged it felt too
easy I felt like I needed to go out and
just earn it I needed to make the
sacrifice I needed to struggle I needed
to confront my problem so you do know I
have surgery did you get into some kind
of a wait a special diet program no no
diet program no surgery what I actually
did while I was in the hospital I did
meet with a couple of nutritionists
dietitians
which helped me learn about portion
control and meal sizing and how that
you'd breakfast and how they eat the
right amount of food and I took the
material that they gave me and just ran
with it
and figured out what I could eat to get
by into drinking a lot of water and the
exercise that I started out doing just
walking things like that and that was
really all I did just a lot of research
just on my own so you started with
walking and did running become part of
it eventually yeah it certainly did I
started out walking actually at the
weight that I was I was on oxygen for a
time so I started out walking I just
pushing a grocery cart around while
so I'd have something to lean on that
was my only exercise that I could do and
I do that three times a week and then I
would just slowly increase it over time
and then before long I could walk to the
end of my driveway and back and
eventually I did take up running and
sadly and I know you've done some
running and you'll relate to this I blew
out my knee about about a year and a
half ago and because of the weight that
I carried for so long I've got bad knees
and so they told me I had to stop
running so I don't run anymore but I've
taken up the bike
so I've you know switched to something
else
yeah I did run for a time and did
running some races and really enjoyed it
was glad that I got to do it but if I
keep doing it my knees won't last very
long so I've switched other thing here
you so what do you weigh now I am down
to 199 when that works yes sir I've been
at that weight for probably about six
months or so so that's where I'm at is
that the lowest that is the lowest
absolutely I haven't weighed 199 it's
probably grade school so it's but but I
know that maintaining is more important
than anything no I'm I'm not interested
in losing any more weight I really don't
care I'm very you know ecstatic at the
beaut this weight you know but I do have
to maintain it I do have to keep an eye
on it well your pictures you look great
in the video as I say the video is
really really really inspiring it's
pretty amazing
so you basically watched portion size
and exercised your weight off I did the
one thing that I figured out is just
like you always say you have to be
intentional about everything you do you
have to decide to do it I figured a
couple of things that really worked for
me one was the set of routines I think
that about 90% of what we do is routine
based and there's only about 10% of it
where we actually deviate from that so I
really flourished under a routine I also
write everything down as much as I love
my smartphone on my computer and
everything I've found that putting that
pen to paper and making a list of the
things that I eat every day and totaling
it up really keeps me accountable so the
other thing it's funny you always talk
about not worshipping your credit score
and I always tell people not to worship
the scale I actually
only way once a month I restrict myself
to the only way and once a month because
I don't want to become overly addicted
to being on the scale the normal
fluctuations will drive you bananas oh
absolutely yeah you can go up or down
five ten pounds in a day you know just
based on the things that you're eating
and stuff like that so so that works for
me to restrict myself and you know hold
myself back from getting addicted to the
scale and then just trying to focus on
moving forward forgetting about the past
there are other times that I gained and
lost weight and it's very traumatic to
gain it all back and all that stuff and
I just forgot about all I cared about
was just extending my life that's all I
think about is just moving forward the
future and so on the reason we ran into
your story was while you're losing 400
pounds you also lost all your debt I did
yes I managed to lose 400 pounds and
also lose $60,000 over that four years
in lose 60,000 paid 60,000 off yes it's
gone forever which I you know I thank
you for what you do and just the daily
reinforcement that I would get from
listening to your show on the Dave
Ramsey app just while I'm out walking
around on my walks it really helps to
hear people that are worse off than I
was because I thought I was in an
impossible hole with the amount of money
that I owed but then you hear somebody
that makes twenty thousand dollars a
year and has three hundred thousand
dollars in student loans you suddenly
feel like well maybe I don't have it so
bad yeah and but yeah it my overeating
was so closely tied into my overspending
it was like they were just one in the
same you know I would my biggest
creditor was American Express and I'm
pleased to report that I finally left
home without it there they are gone from
my life forever and at the beautiful
feeling is fun but I would make the
minimum payment you know then once the
credit became available from the payment
that I've made you know then I would be
in the faster you drive through yeah you
know buying the food and overeating and
binge eating and things like that so
they were one of the same and it really
helped to double down on both at the
same time Brian I got
I'm amazed with you I'm proud of you and
you're an inspiration folks you need to
go to Brian's website vry aan Gainey
gan a why.com Brian Gainey calm and read
about his story and look at the pictures
you can also find it on our site and you
can find a video that he sent us in that
is just inspiring on the weight loss and
on the debt reduction as well and you
can find all of that at Dave Ramsey calm
and man what it's just a wonderful story
someone gets their life back
you